We're here, married. Nothing went wrong. Even my mother behaved herself.
He set eyes on me for the first time hello, hello and i saw a man who, wasn't wearing a jacket
Nonsense.
Oh, yes and trousers with a mend in the knee. Did you think then it was love at first sight?
Marry that girl.
What?
Actually i'm a little bit scared.
What does his father do?
You mean is he working class or one of us?
That's... more or less what I mean.
You don't seem quite as happy as you should.
Something's bothering you, Flo.
Come on Flo it's easy just point and choose.
Something about yourself... a little delicate.
The sex manual says women are like doorways, men can enter through them.
God's sake, Flo. How long have you been there?
I thought I'd just--
I asked you a question, damnit.
Are you alright?
I'm feeling rather sick.
What is it, darling?
Nothing.
Flo, you can change your mind.
I really have to go.
We can never be happy. And it's all my stupid fault.
Have you actually forgotten that we were married today?
We're man and wife! That's what you promised!
To me!
It's hopeless.
Is it?